six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number let's go to
our caller from the six one zero area
code and see let's see what we get with
six one zero today
good afternoon David thank you for your
time well one of the biggest concerns I
have is the scam of the banking system
why has no one ever picked up on
President Kennedy's presidential order 1
1 1 1 0 it's it it just seems like you
know between the fractional banking of
the regular banks and and the Federal
Reserve the way they are treating the
American taxpayers it will never get out
of tell me specifically what you mean
what is the specific way in which
American taxpayers are being treated
poorly by banks well first of all the
Federal Reserve specifically again
President Kennedy presidential order 1 1
1 1 0 would have allowed the US Treasury
to print its own currency and which
would have taken the you know the making
of our own currency back into our hands
of the government as opposed to the
Federal Reserve which makes money out of
nothing and charges of interest for it
that's not unique to the United States
ok can you be a little more specific
about the way in which the banking
system that's what I'm saying well
actually you're right it's you're right
it's not specific to the United States
right it's not a default and we're
saying neutral so that people understand
how exactly is that hurting taxpayers
today well what because then they sell
that the once they get the note from the
from the Treasury Department they being
then they go ahead they being oh oh
the the Federal Reserve I'm sorry the
Federal Reserve gets the ending who from
the US Treasury when the US Congress
approves more spending alright and and
what happens is if you and I were to
write a check like they do with no
thing in our account we would get daily
we'd get thrown in jail okay and then so
how is so let's let's close the circle
because you said the people or get the
taxpayers get screwed by the banks
how are the taxpayers getting by the
banks well then here it is why aren't we
just issuing our own money instead of
having to pay interest to a bank that is
making money out of nothing we we who we
the Treasury Department as in Kennedy's
presidential order one one one one zero
it would have allowed the US Treasury to
print currency as opposed to that
Federal Reserve and then what would
happen well I mean at least we would
have to pay the interest that we do into
the Federal Reserve okay all right thank
you a very very good point I'm gonna
research that it I appreciate you
voicing that concern and I think it is
one that is we've not gotten a call
about that before and that is the first
call we've gotten about it